while making is the huge tradition of my
family and all my ancestors I feel that
this was their lifestyle for us
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this great big story is by Georgia
National Tourism administration
winemaking in Georgia dates back almost
eight thousand years in fact according
to the National Academy of Sciences it's
been proven that this country was the
birthplace of wine with over 40
vineyards the tradition of winemaking
remains strong today but what makes
Georgian wine so different Georgian wine
making style is the oldest one in the
whole world
it's begins eight thousand years ago my
name is parabola tip and I'm winemaker
Georgian wine is really different
firstly the unique and indigenous grape
varieties we have in our country there
are 525 indigenous grape variety in
Georgia we are using at about 25 grave
into the massive production and the
second reason we are having the
different winemaking method this unique
method is fermenting wine with grape
skins and also the vessel of winemaking
query these circles on the floor are the
tops of query those are huge clay pots
which are buried inside and it makes
great one because of the temperature
control to the holier inside we don't
use the modern technologies or
refrigerators they are stable because
they are into the ground so it's the
mother nature perfect for great wine and
really rare wine in the world
Georgia has a huge amount of the
hospitality involve blood it means a lot
for us to have the guest for us it's
really important to preserve the
traditional winemaking methods because
if we do not do this no one will do this
in the near future we want to give this
unique taste for generations and
generations afterwards
[Music]
you
[Music]